Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir à toutes et tous.
Je m’appelle Isabelle Rouhan
et j’ai 18 ans,
avec 27 ans d’expérience.
Quand j’ai commencé à travailler
à la fin des années 90,
le métier à la mode,
c’était consultant dans une boîte d’audit,
comme par exemple Arthur Andersen,
entreprise qui n’existe plus aujourd’hui.
En 2020, les métiers à la mode,
ce sont développeuse
ou bien encore data scientist.
Des métiers qui n’existaient pas
il y a vingt ans.
Le fait majeur de l’emploi,
c’est que le métier que vous exercerez
dans une dizaine d’années
n’existe probablement pas encore.
L’Institut du futur, qui est un think tank
californien financé par Dell,
a démontré que dans 85 % des cas,
le métier que vous exercerez en 2030
n’a pas encore été inventé.
Mon propos aujourd’hui est
de vous démontrer
que les métiers et l’emploi
changent constamment,
que nous vivons une quatrième
révolution technologique
et qu’il faut accueillir celle-ci
avec enthousiasme.
C’est un futur désirable
et nous allons voir ensemble pourquoi.
L’Humanité a traversé
quatre grandes périodes
qui ont transformé le travail et l'emploi.
Toutes ont été chamboulées
par une révolution technologique.
La première se situe au 18e siècle,
avec l’arrivée de la machine à vapeur
qui déclenche l'industrialisation
et l'exode rural.
La seconde, c’est au début du 20e
siècle, avec l’électrification,
qui va créer le travail à la chaîne.
La troisième se situe
dans les années 70 à 2000
avec la micro-informatique
en entreprise et à domicile,
qui va créer
la tertiarisation de l’économie.
Et enfin, la quatrième,
au début des années 2010,
avec l’accélération de
l’intelligence artificielle et du digital
qui crée ce que j’ai appelé
les emplois 4.0.
Ce qui change fondamentalement le travail,
c'est l'automatisation.
Une étude de McKinsey a démontré que la
moitié des heures travaillées en France
est potentiellement automatisable
d'ici 2022.
Je vous rassure,
ça ne veut pas dire que la moitié des
emplois vont disparaître - heureusement.
Ce que dit cette étude
quand on regarde dans le détail,
c’est que 5 % des postes pourraient être
supprimés du fait de l’automatisation.
Moi, je trouve que
c’est une très bonne nouvelle.
Une tâche qu’on automatise,
c’est toujours une tâche répétitive
et c’est très souvent une tâche
qui est pénible et rébarbative.
En revanche, dans 60% des cas,
le métier va être partiellement automatisé
et c’est là que tout se joue.
Comment apprend-on ?
Comment se forme-t-on ?
Comment se transforme-t-on ?
Ce qu'il faut avoir en tête, c'est que le
digital crée de nombreuses opportunités.
Une étude menée par Eurostat,
l’institut statistique européen
équivalent notre INSEE,
démontre que d’ici 2025,
le digital va créer 15 millions
d’emplois en Europe
et, en parallèle, en détruire 6 millions.
On voit bien que la balance est positive.
Mon propos aujourd’hui
est de vous démontrer que l’automatisation
n’est pas l’ennemie de l’emploi.
L’automatisation est même
l’amie de l’emploi
pour peu qu’on veuille bien
devenir son ami.
Et pour cela, je voudrais déjà
un peu replacer dans le contexte
ce qu’est l’intelligence artificielle,
ce qu’elle sait faire,
ce qu’elle ne sait pas faire.
J’ai choisi un exemple avec des chats.
Quand on parle de digital,
il faut souvent parler de petits chats.
En l’occurrence, c’est un exemple
mené à bien par une start-up
qui s’appelle Pix2Pix,
qui, depuis, a été rachetée par Google.
Ce que fait Pix2Pix,
c’est du machine learning.
Ils rendent un ordinateur apprenant.
Et en l’occurrence,
ils ont montré à cet ordinateur
beaucoup de photos
de tout un tas de petits chatons
et la machine, elle sait ensuite recréer
à partir d’une simple esquisse,
que vous voyez là derrière moi,
une photo de petit chat.
Et ça ressemble réellement
à un petit chat.
Sauf que la machine qui fait ça,
elle ne sait pas qu’un chaton,
c’est mignon,
ça ronronne,
elle ne sait pas qu’un chaton,
on peut le caresser.
Rien ne remplace l'expérience humaine.
L’automatisation est l’amie de l’emploi
et les chiffres le prouvent.
Déjà, à chacune des révolutions
technologiques que je vous ai citées,
il y a eu plus de créations d’emplois
que de destructions.
J’en veux pour preuve le fait
que la population active en France
était de 17 millions de personnes
au 19e siècle,
aujourd’hui, elle est de 30 millions.
Par ailleurs, les pays les plus robotisés
au monde que sont l'Allemagne et le Japon
ont le taux de chômage
le plus bas, autour de 3%.
Et enfin, on a beaucoup
de marge de progression
sur le sujet de la robotisation.
Vous avez en France 19 robots
pour 1000 salariés.
Il y en a 21 en Italie, 34 en Allemagne,
77 en Corée du Sud.
On a donc une marge de progression
qui est extrêmement importante.
L’automatisation est l’amie de l’emploi,
oui, mais à certaines conditions.
Il y a trois défis majeurs à relever
si vous voulez faire de l’automatisation
l’amie de votre emploi.
Le premier défi, c’est l’obsolescence
accélérée des compétences
et notamment des compétences techniques.
L’OCDE a démontré que dans les années 70,
une compétence technique
avait une durée de vie de 20 ans.
On allait à l’école, on se formait,
on apprenait un métier,
on se reformait éventuellement
à mi-carrière,
c’était assez linéaire.
Ça, c'est fini.
Une compétence technique qui a aujourd’hui
une durée de vie entre 12 et 18 mois,
elle aura en 2025
une durée de vie d’un an.
Ça veut dire deux choses.
La première, c’est qu’il faut
se former en permanence
et la seconde, qu’on ne peut plus
capitaliser sur ses compétences.
Bonne nouvelle, il y a
un autre type de compétences,
les compétences de savoir-être,
les fameuses soft skills :
le leadership, l’agilité,
la capacité d’apprendre à apprendre,
ce qu’on cultive tous ensemble ce soir,
à ce TEDxRoubaix.
Ces compétences-là,
elles sont comme le bon vin,
elles se bonifient avec le temps.
Deuxième défi majeur,
c’est l’essor des services à la personne.
On manque de gens
pour s’occuper de nos enfants,
on manque de gens
pour s’occuper de nos aînés,
pour s’occuper de nos clients.
Je crois que toute personne qui a passé
plus de cinq minutes
à retaper son code client sur un téléphone
pour parler à un serveur vocal
voit à peu près de quoi je parle.
Pour illustrer ce point-là
et illustrer à quel point l’automatisation
peut être notre amie dans ce cas précis,
j’ai été jusqu’à Montréal
rencontrer le patron du CHUM.
Le CHUM, c’est le Centre hospitalier
universitaire de Montréal.
Il est dirigé par un Français,
le professeur Fabrice Brunet.
Lui, il a automatisé
une tâche, une seule :
le fait de pousser des chariots.
Il a créé une autoroute des robots
dans son hôpital, sur 26 étages.
Et du coup, il amène
directement dans les étages
la nourriture, les médicaments, les draps,
et il fait évacuer les déchets
par des robots.
Il n’a pas licencié les magasiniers pour
autant, qu’il a gardés dans ses équipes.
Il en a formé une petite partie,
à peu près 5 %,
à devenir contrôleur qualité de robots.
Et surtout, aux autres, il leur a proposé
de changer de métier,
de devenir logisticien,
de répartir dans les étages les affaires
qui étaient amenées par les robots,
tâches qui avaient été effectuées
par les soignants.
Son indicateur de succès,
ce ne sont pas les économies,
ce n’est pas le nombre d’emplois
qu’il a supprimés.
C'est la vitesse de guérison des malades
et c'est la rapidité de leur sortie.
Et les deux se sont améliorés.
L’automatisation à bon escient
est à la fois l’amie de l’emploi
et l’amie des humains.
Dernier défi, et c’est d’ailleurs
plus un paradoxe qu’un défi,
le numérique est le secteur
qui recrute le plus en France.
Pour autant, il y a
80 000 postes non pourvus
dans notre économie,
dans le secteur du numérique,
du fait d’un déficit de compétences.
Il manque 900 000 codeuses et codeurs
à l’échelle européenne en 2021.
C’est vraiment dommage parce qu’on peut
tout à fait se former à ces métiers-là.
Ils sont complètement accessibles, quel
que soit le niveau d’études après bac.
Ce ne sont pas forcément
des métiers de bac +5.
J’en veux pour preuve le fait que
l’école Simplon, financée par Microsoft,
qui forme des publics éloignés de l’emploi
aux métiers du digital,
a proposé à des hôtes
et des hôtesses de caisse
de devenir développeurs
et développeuses Java.
Ça fonctionne.
Tout le monde peut changer de métier
pour peu qu'on l'accompagne.
Pour terminer et conclure,
je voudrais partager avec vous
trois facteurs clés de succès
qui font, selon moi, de l’automatisation
l’amie de votre prochain emploi.
Le premier, c’est l’agilité.
On va avoir entre six et neuf
métiers dans notre vie.
Six, c’est un chiffre qui sort d’Harvard,
du chercheur Bob Kegan -
il dit même 6,5 ; je n’ai pas trouvé
ce qu’était le demi, on va en rester là -
et neuf, c’est un chiffre qui vient
du World Economic Forum.
La vérité est sûrement entre les deux.
Néanmoins, si vous voulez être
employable toute votre vie,
il y a une agilité à cultiver en
particulier, c’est celle de votre réseau.
Je ne parle pas des réseaux sociaux,
je ne parle pas de LinkedIn,
je parle de la capacité à aller
échanger à la machine à café
avec un collègue, avec un fournisseur,
avec quelqu’un d’une entreprise.
Je parle de ce que
vous avez fait à la pause
dans le hall du Colisée à Roubaix :
de jolies rencontres qui vont enrichir
vos différents points de vue.
Deuxième facteur clé de succès,
c’est la diversité.
Bien sûr, il y a celle de genre,
sur le dessin humoristique
que vous voyez derrière moi,
mais il y en a d’autres types :
les générations, le handicap,
l’orientation sexuelle
et l’origine sociale et culturelle.
Tous ces facteurs-là,
on doit les prendre en compte,
bien sûr pour des raisons
éthiques, de valeurs,
mais aussi
pour des raisons de performance.
Une étude de McKinsey, là encore, faite
sur 1 000 entreprises dans 12 pays,
a démontré que quand on avait une
gouvernance à parité dans une entreprise,
la surperformance était de 5 %.
Quand la gouvernance réunit les cinq
types de diversité que je vous ai cités,
la surperformance est de 15 %.
Et inversement, pour le dernier quartile,
les 25 % d’entreprises les moins diverses,
la sous-performance est de 27 %.
Donc, la diversité,
c’est un facteur clé de succès.
Quand vous serez candidat ou candidate
pour votre prochain métier du futur,
faites attention aux recruteurs,
que ce ne soit pas comme cette image.
Faites en sorte qu'ils ne
se ressemblent pas trop.
Et enfin, dernier facteur clé de succès,
c’est celui qu’on cultive
tous ensemble ce soir.
C’est pour ça que vous venez à un TEDx.
C'est la capacité d'apprendre à apprendre.
C’est la curiosité.
L’agent Smith a dit dans Matrix :
« N’envoyez jamais un humain
faire le travail d’une machine. »
Il a raison.
Mais l’inverse est vrai aussi :
n’envoyez jamais une machine
faire le travail d’un humain.
Les deux sont complémentaires.
Je vous souhaite de magnifiques
futurs désirables.
Que l’automatisation soit
l’amie de votre emploi.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)